STEVE: FINAL PROTECTION DIRECTOR
MICK MULVANEY SPOKE ABOUT HIS
TIME IN CONGRESS.
HE SAID IF YOU ARE A LOBBIEST
THAT NEVER GAVE US MONEY I NEVER
TALKED TO YOU.
IF YOU DID GIVE US MONEY I SPOKE
TO YOU.
THEY SAID HE'S STILL AT IT.
EIGHT REGISTERED LOBBYIST HAVE
DONATED TO HIS CONGRESSIONAL
CAMPAIGN GOT A MEETING WITH
MULVANEY AFTER HE BECAME BUDGET
DIRECTOR.
OF COURSE THAT'S OUTRAGEOUS.
MANY PEOPLE GOT ON THE MULVANEY
BASHING BANDWAGON.
AMONG THEM WAS DEMOCRAT BOB
CASEY.
HE SAID THIS IS SUPPOSE TO BE A
GOVERNMENT BY THE PEOPLE FOR THE
PEOPLE NOT OF THE THIEVES AND
MONEY CHANGERS.
MULVANEY IS A DISGRACE.
INTERESTING, I AGREE.
BOB CASEY WOULD NEVER ISSUE A
THUNDERING DENOUNCATION OF HIS
LOBBYIST TIES IF HE TOOK MONEY
FROM LOBBYIST.
THAT WOULD BE SHAMELESSLY
DISHONEST.
BOB CASEY IS THIS WEEKS SWAMP
WATCH.
HE RAGED AGAINST MULVANEY OVER
DONATIONS FROM LOBBYIST.
WE'LL GET TO THAT IN A MOMENT.
HERE IS AN APPEAR
HERE IS AN APPETR
HERE IS AN APPETIZER FOR YOU.
NATHAN WAS THE ASSISTANT FROM
2007 TO 2009 BEFORE JOINING STUN
GROUP.
THEY BROUGHT HIM $8 MILLION
WORTH OF LOBBYING CONTRACTS
INCLUDING FOR FINANCE AND
HEALTHCARE PHARMACEUTICAL
CONTRACTS.
THAT'S HANDY.
ANOTHER PERSON JARED SULLIVAN
SEVERED AS BUDGET POLICY AT AN
ADD HAVE
AND HAVE
ANGRHAVE
ANGROUVE
ANGROUP.
HIS CLIENTS INCLUDED THE
AMERICAN INDIAN HIGHER EDUCATION
ORGANIZE.
OF COURSE HE LOBBIED FOR
EDUCATION INTEREST.
HIS FORMER BOSS SERVES ON THE
SENATE COMMITTEE THAT OVERSEES
EDUCATION.
THAT'S HOW IT WORKS IN THE
SWAMP.
THERE IS CASEY THAT'S BEEN
THROUGH THE DOOR SO MUCH.
I'M SHOCKED SHE'S NOT BUSY.
SHE LEFT TO BETHE ASSISTANT
DIRECTOR OF GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS.
THE NEXT YEAR SHE WENT BACK TO
WASHINGTON WORKING FOR DEBBY,
BOB CASEY, AND HARRY REID.
IN REID'S OFFICE SHE WORKED FOR
AGRICULTURE.
THEN SHE BECAME A LOBBYIST FOR
MONSANTO.
DON'T YOU LOVE THE WAY HE
ATTACKS MULVANEY OF LOBBYIST BUT
HE'S DONE SO MUCH HIMSELF.
YOU MIGHT SAY THOSE ARE HIS
STAFFERS.
HE'S NOT PART OF THE SWAMP.
HE'S CLEAN AS A WHISTLE.
HE WOULD NEVER CALL HIM A
DISGRACE.
THIS SHOWS THE PEOPLE WHO
DONATED TO HIS CAMPAIGN.
TWO OF THE SECTORS OF THE
HIGHEST DONATIONS ARE INDUSTRIES
HE REGULATES AS PART OF HIS
COMMITTEE ASSIGNMENTS INCLUDING
1.58 MILLION FROM THE REAL
ESTATE SECTOR AND 1.2 MILLION
FROM THE ESTATE SECTOR.
DONATIONS FROM LOBBYIST, THERE
IS NO WAY HE WOULD GO ON THE
WARPATH IF HE DID THE SAME
THING, WOULD HE?
OH, LOOK, ACCORDING TO
RESPONSIVE POLITICS ON APRIL 25,
2017.
HE TOOK A 2,700 DONATION FROM
BEN FARMS.
A LOBBYIST.
HE TOOK MONEY FROM ANOTHER
LOBBYIST.
ON MARCH 20th HE TOOK $500
FROM THE ANOTHER GROUP.
HE TOOK MONEY FROM ALPINE GROUP.
A FIRM THAT INCLUDES TWO
HEALTHCARE GIANTS.
THEY ARE BOTH EFFECTED BY THE
SENATE HEALTH COMMITTEE.
HE TOOK MONEY FROM LOBBY FIRMS.
THEY MIGHT BE INTERESTED IN THE
FACT THAT HE SERVES ON THE
AGRICULTURE AND FOREST TRY
COMMITTEE.
HE SALARIES TOOK MONEY FROM A
BANK.
CASEY IS ON THE SENATE FINANCE
COMMITTEE.
ALL TOLD HE TOOK 198 DONATIONS
FROM 136 LOBBYIST IN THE 2018
ELECTION CYCLES.
HERE ARE THEIR NAMES SCROLLING
ON THE SCREEN.
THIS HYPOCRITE SO EAGER TO JUMP
DOWN MICK'S THROAT HE TOOK
$177,000 FROM LOBBYIST IN THE
2018 ELECTION CYCLE.
82,000 FROM LOBBYIST IN TO 2016
CYCLE.
293,000 FROM LOBBYIST IN THE
2012 CYCLE.
IT ADDS UP TO A GRAND TOTAL OF
$675,000 FROM LOBBYIST IN HIS
SENATE CAREER.
WHO KNOWS WHAT FAVORS HE DID FOR
ALL OF THAT CRASH.
WE WANT TO FIND OUT.
WE'LL SUBMIT A INFORMATION
REQUEST TO SEE WHO HE AND HIS
STAFF HAS MET WITH.
HE INVITED HIM TO COME TO THE
SHOW BUT TURNED DOWN OUR OFFER.
HE ADMITTED TO SELLING ACCESS TO
HIM AND HIS OFFICE IN EXCHANGE
FOR DONATIONS.
SENATOR CASEY IS PASSING REFORM.
NOTICE, HE DOESN'T DENY SELLING
ACCESS TO HIM AND HIS OFFICE.
SENATOR CASEY, YOU ARE THE
DISGRACE.
YOU PEACH ABOUT GETTING MONEY
OUT OF POLITICS WHILE PROGETTING
FROM
PROM
PROGIT --PROFITTING FROM HUNDRED